all right folks as always I'm going to
do my personal opinion of the movie
we're under do this week it's a bummer
view in dystocia Creek um and this week
is obviously transformers 3 what did I
think of it well of course you can't
talk about the second sequel unless you
talk about what you thought of the other
films of first transformers I liked I
did enjoy if I was good action pretty
funny
dumbass characters dumbass story but I
thought it was fun and people don't like
it I totally get it I'm not going to
defend it it's stupid but I thought it's
a lot of fun too
the second one I didn't like but I
didn't hate as much as I think a lot of
other people did my biggest problem is
that I really thought I was just
repeating the first film again and it's
just kind of annoying you get those
twins that you know we never shut up and
I like an hour in the desert just people
shooting so those are my problem and now
we got transformers 3 and basically it
allows it's the same problem as the
second one it's just doing the first
movie again except this time there's a
major difference that you could argue
makes it worse than the second it's not
annoying it's boring it's ungodly boring
to me I know I said this this is me
talking for others because I I went to a
midnight show and it was like all high
schoolers pretty much and sure enough
when the credits roll at the end of her
work I mean they loved it so there's
definitely an audience out there for it
still but yet might be prom is that I
I've seen this I've seen this done
before you can literally just pinpoint
what moment they're gonna do it's okay
you have the buildup in the opening
without those Prime's narration then
you're gonna go to what's that same kid
up to Oh his parents are gonna come and
embarrass him well they'll go away for a
bit come in maybe beginning of the
second act to say something really
stupid again but still like you know
encouraging because there is parents um
you know and
then you got the government cover-up you
know with you know optics pranks that
you lied to us you you know I hit making
the big speeches and it just seems so I
don't say phoned in because these movies
take a lot of effort in it looks huge um
but it's story wise it just seems like
we've seen this um the only thing that
was well there's two things that were
new about what is the new girlfriend
which I do like better than Megan Fox um
I actually like the fact that of course
they it's Michael bass and they make her
as hell um but it's still a nice
character here and maybe it's just the
British accent maybe the British accent
just totally throws me off and just like
what she's sweet she's nice but the
characters seem like you know let Jimmy
Leo this is likeable she's very likeable
where Megan Fox
I don't member hating matches I don't
remember I don't remember think about
her um and the other thing that's kind
of new is the Decepticons are a little
bit more creative they're a lot of fun
there's there's a vulture Decepticon
there's like this the one way I can
describe it is sort of like a worm from
dune Decepticon and that thing's great I
mean that thing came on I got excited um
but everything else just seems like okay
the buildings explode the people are
falling you know and then and you think
they're gonna fall they're not gonna
make it but then of course at the last
minute the Autobots coming catch him and
save them and you see okay
in the first Transformers I remember
once one part where everyone really
applauded was when Optimus Prime he gets
distracted near the entity he has to
fight this other whatever bad guy and
then they all go into the city they're
fighting fighting fighting and then
somewhere in the middle of it prime
suddenly comes in everybody applauds and
that was good that's sort of like when
Gandalf came in in two towers this are
like oh yeah you sort of forgot about
him uh they really abuse that here I
mean they do it like eight times I mean
there's like eight times where the
Autobots go
you know you quote-unquote think they're
gone and then just when someone's about
to get shot just when they played in
slo-mo and play the Sam you
they come over the hill and hit the guy
and the first couple times they did you
know of course the teen audience goes oh
yeah by the 12-time I mean it's like
they could just see it coming um so that
was pretty predictable uh it was kind of
cool seeing Chicago get blown up I mean
cuz I we sort of saw you know the
explosions happening and stuff so I mean
it's neat to see oh okay that's what it
looked like um but nothing I get nothing
that's picked Acula in and I like the
action in the first Transformers I
thought the second one again just three
when we saw that um and this one it's
yeah we're just raiding the city again
and here's a good example of just how
it's the exact same movie again you know
what was the climax in the first one it
was the city and what was the middle
action scene it was in the desert well
okay
the second movie was the climax the
desert okay we saw that now this movie
what's the climax the city we saw that
and it just it floors me how they these
are aliens from space I mean these are
machines that can turn into things I
mean it just thinks go into space and
fight you know go to another country and
fight you know Egypt oh okay it's still
desert you know it's still sand flying
up in the air you know it just seems
like you could get a lot more creative
with what you can do these things I like
said with the Decepticons they sort of
do you know that this vulture thing can
sort of turn into you know almost like
pictures and take and mimics a lot of
various things that that tapeworm uh uh
transformer what was pretty cool I love
to watch an anything move but aside from
that I just didn't see anything new and
an Arabic disappointment is how um was
it the Shia LaBeouf kid I don't hate
Shia LeBouf by the way I cuz I know like
he has like this big hate following I
really I I'm one of the people I don't
hate him you know I got nothing is
anything great got nothing again I
thought it was funny in the first one
here for whatever reason they have him
shout all the time like every other line
it's a scream and he doesn't even need
to I mean it's just like
girlfriend God and he's just he's
Constance creamy I'm at one point where
they pull up and he's gonna wine her to
ease me I want to auto pots again I
won't do this sceptic ever ever um and I
remember he pulls up in his car is as
you know I want see Optimus Prime I want
sees is that whatever the secret
location and the soldiers are just like
no you can't see him no you kiss and at
some point he just has like a Nicholas
Cage mobile Rachel's just once I I don't
even know what was guy I think he like
goes he like runs into a gauge or
something like then the car gets he
checked up a little bit and he's just
like ah it's like I have no idea what
that was about I mean maybe maybe other
people then they it's just on my MS but
it seemed like he was just screaming
every other wine um there's this bad guy
that Patrick Dempsey play I don't think
giving anything away by saying he's a
bad guy
um the plot of coke that's what have you
ever cared about a plot and a
transformer movie um so yeah my and it's
not as annoying as the second one but I
I don't see any purpose in seeing it uh
it's literally to go watch the first one
again the actions there the acting is
very the comedies better you never care
about the story so you don't really want
to know what's gonna happen um there's a
lot of jokes that fall dead um there's
one good joke I remember and that's when
you I'd be when that giant worm thing
comes around wrapping around the
building one of the soldiers just says
you know why the hell do the Decepticons
get all the better I think it's a
very legitimate question so um and
there's just one other way of thing IG I
brought in the bomb review um for
whatever reason like they okay you know
how like in trailers I do this too and
trailers like you know somebody says a
line and then all of a sudden boom it
goes black I mean that's just what
happens you know somebody turns dude you
know it's just that's always what
happens this movie really starts again
just really abusing that and I don't
know why they play the same guy did the
music for inception did
this I guess so it's just there's the
inception music I guess that makes it
okay um try thinking what else I did not
see it in 3d and okay but before I sign
off I might give you one thing just a
little lesson about 3d cuz I'm someone I
don't think 3d is horrible 3d can be
great but here's how you can spot a good
3d movie if it's gonna look good in 3d
okay uh then let's say you're watching
me in 3d this would look cool this would
look really awesome now with this look
cool in 3d no you can't see anything
it's dark wet and blurry there we go
it's dark and it's blurry that's not
gonna look as good them better you can
see something the better the 3d is gonna
be and the more clear it is and the more
more still it is and the more colorful
is the better it's going to look so
something like a Kung Fu Panda 2 very
good in 3d a lot of animated films are
very good in 3d because they make it
very bright and colorful um you know how
train your dragon was very good my
avatar looks so good in 3d because they
made you know the characters are blue
for God's sake I mean it's that colorful
uh so for something like this that's
mostly just rubble and a lot of it I
mean there's Michael Bay movies are
already pretty hard to watch I cannot
imagine watching this in 3d so it's all
Knights goodness for you um I can't
imagine watching us in 3d or on IMAX cuz
it just it's hard enough just to watch
on the small screen half the time so um
but like I said when we was done
watching it I mean a lot of people were
applauding they were getting into it so
my guess is if you like transformers 2
you'll probably like this ok um you know
and I know people are sort of split up
the first one like whether or not you
know today was this fun or incredibly
stupid I think it's both um but no I I
didn't enjoy watching it personally I
thought it was way too long as usual I
thought it's just rehashing the same
stuff again not as annoying but lysa it
was boring for me and I you couldn't
argue that's a worse crime than being
annoying at least annoying makes an
impact
um so yeah that's my two cents on it you
could like it but didn't do much for me
so that's it nice show talk to you later